ALL RIGHT. THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE WILL
COME. COMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING TO EVERYONE.
WELCOME, WE DO HAVE ONLY ONE
MEASURE ON TODAY'S AGENDA. AND I
DO HAVE AN ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF ONE
OF OUR COMMITTEE STAFF MEMBERS
RIGHT AFTER THAT. SO I HOPE
THOSE WHO CAN STAY FOR A FEW
MINUTES AFTER THE FIRST ITEM,
WE'LL DO SO, I ASSURE YOU, IT
WILL ONLY BE A COUPLE OF
MINUTES, WE WANT TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AT THIS TIME, SO I'M
GOING TO ASK THE COMMITTEE
ASSISTANT TO DO THAT. WE'RE
MISSING ONE. ALL RIGHT. SO WE
ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. WE'LL DO
THAT AS SOON AS WE CAN. BUT THE
AUTHOR IS HERE, SO WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE SENATOR WIENER PLEASE
PRESENT HIS BILL. GREAT. PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES. I'M HERE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL 530. EXCUSE ME. 532,
WHICH MODERNIZES PARKING
PAYMENTS BY AUTHORIZING, BUT NOT
REQUIRING A FIVE YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM FOR THREE PILOT CITIES
THAT HAVE ALL ASKED TO BE
INCLUDED SAN FRANCISCO, LONG
BEACH AND SANTA MONICA. TO
IMPLEMENT PAID PARKING WITHOUT
HAVING TO INCUR THE HIGH COST OF
PHYSICAL PARKING METERS. A
CURRENT LAW EFFECTIVELY REQUIRES
CITIES TO SPEND PRECIOUS
RESOURCES PURCHASING,
INSTALLING, AND MAINTAINING, AT
TIMES OUTDATED AND EXPENSIVE
PARKING METER EQUIPMENT THAT
TAKE UP SPACE ON SIDEWALKS. LAST
YEAR, FOR EXAMPLE, PHYSICAL
METERS COST SAN FRANCISCO $26
MILLION TO INSTALL AND MAINTAIN.
BASICALLY ABOUT HALF OF SAN
FRANCISCO'S PARKING REVENUE GOES
TO THE PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
INSTEAD OF TO OTHER NEEDS,
PARKING METERS ARE OFTEN
VANDALIZED, TAKE UP A LOT OF
SPACE, AND THIS SPACE COULD BE
FREED TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
PEOPLE, INCLUDING PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES, TO GET BY. AND SO
SB 532 WILL ALLOW THE THREE
PILOT CITIES TO PILOT PARKING
METER LESS, PAID PARKING ZONES.
AND PROVIDED THAT THE CITY
PROVIDES SIGNAGE ABOUT HOW TO
PAY IF THE PERSON DOES NOT HAVE
A SMARTPHONE AND HAS REASONABLE
ALTERNATIVE MEANS FOR CASH
PAYMENT. TO BE CLEAR, EXISTING
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT REQUIRE
THAT METERS ACCEPT CASH. YOU CAN
HAVE CREDIT CARD ONLY, BUT WE DO
REQUIRE IN THIS BILL A CASH
OPTION. SO IT IS A FIVE YEAR
PILOT PROGRAM. I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. AND WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SYLVIA
SALAS CHAU, REPRESENTING THE SAN
FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY. PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING, MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. THANK YOU TO
SENATOR WIENER FOR AUTHORING
THIS MEASURE, WHICH WILL ALLOW
SAN FRANCISCO TO MODERNIZE THE
WAY WE ACCEPT PAYMENT AND PAID
PARKING ZONES. AS HE MENTIONED,
IT WILL ALLOW THE CITY TO SAVE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AT A TIME
WHEN OUR BUDGETS ARE VERY TIGHT.
PAID PARKING IS THE BEST TOOL
THAT CITIES HAVE TO CREATE.
PARKING AVAILABILITY, WHICH
BENEFITS BUSINESSES, MINIMIZES
CIRCLING AND DOUBLE PARKING, AND
REDUCES EMISSIONS SPEEDS. PUBLIC
TRANSIT AND MAKE STREETS SAFER
AND MORE EFFICIENT. HOWEVER, WE
CURRENTLY COLLECT PAYMENT FOR
PARKING USING PARKING METERS,
WHICH ARE EXPENSIVE TO MAINTAIN
AND UNFORTUNATELY, EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES CITIES TO USE PHYSICAL
PARKING METERS AND PAY STATIONS
TO ACCEPT PAYMENT FOR PARKING,
AND PROHIBITS MOBILE ONLY
PAYMENT. WE ALSO ARE VERY
MINDFUL AND, EXCITED TO ADDRESS
THE REQUIREMENT THAT WOULD ALLOW
FOR A CASH PAYMENT PLAN IN THESE
MOBILE ONLY AREAS, YOU KNOW, WE
UNDERSTAND THAT NOT EVERYBODY
HAS ACCESS TO OR WANTS TO USE A
MOBILE PHONE TO PAY FOR PARKING
OR, OR THEY MAY NOT HAVE A
CREDIT CARD TO BE ABLE TO PAY
FOR PARKING IN THOSE ZONES. SO
WE LOOK FORWARD TO IMPLEMENTING
THAT AS PART OF THIS BILL. AND
FOR THESE REASONS, SFMTA
SUPPORTS SB 532. I'D ALSO LIKE
TO VOICE THE SUPPORT OF THE CITY
OF SANTA MONICA AND CACTI, THE
CALIFORNIA CITY TRANSPORTATION
INITIATIVE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT?
PLEASE COME FORWARD. NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT, PLEASE.
CHAIR. MEMBERS. MAX PERRY, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LONG BEACH
IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, MISTER
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. MATTHEW
SEIBERLING, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MOBILITY AND PARKING
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO
OTHERS, DO WE HAVE AN OPPOSITION
WITNESS IN THE ROOM? I'VE SEEN
NONE. IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION? SEEING
NONE, WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEN.
NEWMAN. THANK YOU. I JUST, YOU
KNOW, QUICK QUESTION ON THE CASH
PAYMENT, I UNDERSTAND IT'S KIND
OF A WORK IN PROGRESS, BUT HOW
HOW CAN WE DO THAT IN A WAY THAT
ACTUALLY ADDRESSES, YOU KNOW,
THAT EQUITY QUESTION OF PEOPLE
WITHOUT DIGITAL ACCESS. AND THE
GOOD NEWS IS THE CALIFORNIA
WOULD NOT BE SORRY FOR MY VOICE.
CALIFORNIA WOULD NOT BE THE
FIRST STATE TO DO THIS. AS
INDICATED IN THE ANALYSIS. AND
THERE ARE OTHER EXAMPLES AS WELL,
OF CITIES IN VARIOUS PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY THAT HAVE ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED THIS. AND THERE ARE
A FEW WAYS THAT YOU CAN DO IT.
YOU COULD HAVE A PAY BY PHONE,
OPTION. SOME CITIES WILL DO IT
THAT ON ON THE BLOCK WHERE YOU
HAVE THIS, THERE WILL BE A STORE
THAT THE SIGNS WILL INDICATE YOU
CAN GO TO THAT STORE AND PAY,
VIA CASH, THERE IS ALSO A WAY TO
DO IT WHERE YOU WOULD JUST GET
SOMETHING IN THE MAIL AFTERWARDS
TO PAY. SO THERE ARE VARIOUS
OPTIONS, AND OTHER CITIES HAVE
IMPLEMENTED SOME OF THOSE, SOME
OF THOSE OPTIONS. BUT IT'S I
THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT. AND I
SAID THIS AT THE BEGINNING AND
I'LL REITERATE IT, THAT
CALIFORNIA LAW DOES NOT REQUIRE
ACCEPTING CASH TODAY, THAT YOU
CAN HAVE METERS THAT ONLY ACCEPT
CREDIT CARDS. SO IF SOMEONE
DOESN'T HAVE A CREDIT CARD, YOU
KNOW, THEY WOULD HAVE A
CHALLENGE THERE, AS WELL. SO
THAT'S SOMETHING JUST I WANT TO
JUST REITERATE. I APPRECIATE
THAT. I MEAN, I'D BE FINE WITH
WITH NO CASH OPTION, BUT THAT'S
ALWAYS BEEN A POINT OF
CONTENTION IN THESE KINDS OF
DISCUSSIONS HERE. SO I
APPRECIATE IT. YEAH THANK YOU.
YEAH IF THERE'S NO ONE ELSE,
JUST MAKE A QUICK COMMENT. I
KNOW SENATOR WIENER STARTED
TALKING ABOUT THIS BILL A LONG
TIME AGO WITH THE COMMITTEE
STAFF. AND, YOU KNOW, WITH ALL
OF US UP HERE, I THINK AND, YOU
KNOW, MY REACTION WAS
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THAT IT'S A
LIMITED PILOT. THAT, YOU KNOW,
ON SOME OF THESE ISSUES, THE
CITIES WILL MAKE DECISIONS BASED
ON WHETHER OR NOT, YOU KNOW,
THEY CAN CAPTURE REVENUE THE WAY
THEY WANT TO. SO IF THERE'S
ISSUES WITH WI-FI OR ANYTHING
ELSE, I THINK THOSE WILL PLAY
THEMSELVES OUT IN THE PILOT,
WILL INFORM, YOU KNOW, WHERE TO
GO NEXT. SO I THINK IT'S A GOOD
BILL, AND I'M CERTAINLY
SUPPORTIVE, DO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE BILL? I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
READ. OH, DID WE GET A QUORUM
HERE? ALL RIGHT. USED TO THAT.
ALL RIGHT, WELL, WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO. YEAH. TAKE UP THE VOTE
WHEN WE GET A QUORUM CENTER.
WIENER, YOU'RE FREE TO LEAVE.
WE'RE GOING TO. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
STAY, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE JUST A
FEW MOMENTS HERE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
OUR CHIEF COMMITTEE CONSULTANT.
DID YOU WANT TO CLOSE SENATOR
WIENER, YOU MAY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
I'M JUST, RATHER THAN RECESS, WE
WANT THIS ACTUALLY ON THE
RECORD. AS YOU MAY HAVE HEARD,
RANDY CHIN IS RETIRING THIS
YEAR, AND I THINK SOME HAVE SAID
HE'S ACTUALLY RETIRING, AS CHIEF
CONSULTANT, RANDY'S BEEN LEADING
THE COMMITTEE FOR ALMOST TEN
YEARS, WHEN HE TOOK THE WHEEL.
PUN INTENDED. IT WAS A
TRANSPORTATION AND HOUSING
COMMITTEE. AND THEN IN 2019, HE
WEATHERED AN AMICABLE DIVORCE
AND FORGED AHEAD WITH THE
TRANSPORTATION TEAM.
PROFESSIONAL DIVORCE RATE.
RANDY'S BEEN PART OF THE SENATE
FAMILY FOR NEARLY THREE DECADES.
HE BECAME THE CHIEF CONSULTANT
FOR THE SENATE ENERGY, UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE IN
1995. AFTER MOVING OVER FROM THE
ASSEMBLY, UTILITIES AND COMMERCE
COMMITTEE WHEN HE JOINED THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE, RANDY
CHANGED TRACKS FROM ELECTRICITY
SUPPLY TO ELECTRIC CARS,
BECOMING THE SENATE EXPERT ON
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
DEPLOYMENT. ADDITIONALLY, HE HAS
HELPED MEMBERS NAVIGATE SOME
DIFFICULT TRANSPORTATION POLICY
ISSUES SUCH AS SPEED CAMERAS,
GOODS MOVEMENT, AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES, AND OF COURSE, OUTDOOR
ADVERTISING. BUT OF ALL THE
BILLS AND POLICIES RANDY HAS
LEFT HIS MARK ON IN THE
TRANSPORTATION WORLD, THE
BIGGEST HAS TO BE SB ONE. THE
ROAD REPAIR AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT. RANDY ADVISED THE FORMER
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE, SENATOR
JIM BELL, MY PREDECESSOR, THE
FULL SENATE AND THE FULL SENATE
ON THIS LANDMARK PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. AND AS WE ALL KNOW,
SB ONE RAISED BILLIONS IN NEW
REVENUE FOR OUR STATE'S
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK AND TOOK
YEARS TO GET OVER THE FINISH
LINE. RANDY WAS A MAJOR PART OF
THAT SUCCESS. IN ADDITION, IN
ADDITION TO CRAFTING GOOD
POLICY. RANDY HAS ALSO HELPED
SHAPE THE NEXT GENERATION OF
POLICY STAFF, AND I CAN ATTEST
THAT HE'S DONE A TREMENDOUS JOB
OF THAT. HE SERVED AS A MENTOR
FOR THE CCST SCIENCE FELLOWS FOR
MANY YEARS, SHEPHERDING THEM
THROUGH THE HUSTLE AND BUSTLE OF
COMMITTEE WORK AND HELPING MANY
OF THEM TRANSITION TO PERMANENT
COMMITTEE STAFF. LIKE OUR OWN
CONSULTANT TO MY RIGHT, JACOB
O'CONNOR. ON BEHALF OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE SENATE
FAMILY, I WANT TO THANK OUR
CHIEF CONSULTANT FOR HIS SERVICE
TO THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND
HIS CONTRIBUTIONS TO
TRANSPORTATION POLICY. I'VE
CERTAINLY ENJOYED WORKING WITH
RANDY. WHERE DID HE GO? ALL
RIGHT, RANDY, I'VE CERTAINLY
ENJOYED WORKING WITH YOU. I'LL
REPEAT THAT TWICE. IT BEARS
REPEATING MULTIPLE TIMES. YOUR
PROFESSIONALISM, YOUR DILIGENCE,
THE STUFF THAT PEOPLE DON'T SEE
BEHIND THE SCENES. EVEN, YOU
KNOW, JUST THE REGIMEN OF MAKING
SURE WE'RE PREPARED. EVERYONE'S
PREPARED ON SUCH A DETAILED
BASIS. AND THE MENTORING WAS
ALREADY MENTIONED. I'M SORRY TO
SEE YOU GO, BUT HAPPY FOR YOU IN
THE SENSE THAT MAYBE GOLF AND
MAUI AND SOME OTHER THINGS WILL
BE IN YOUR IMMEDIATE FUTURE. AND
IT WASN'T WHY I WAS LATE, BUT I
DID BRING A DE MINIMIS, WE WON'T
EVEN CALL IT THE G WORD, A
DIMINISHMENT, A DE MINIMIS ITEM
HERE THAT YOU MAY WANT TO TAKE
ON YOUR OWN OR POSSIBLY SHARE
WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF, BUT
IT'S JUST A BANANA NUT BREAD.
HOMEMADE. AND I'M NOT WEARING
BLACK IN MOURNING. THIS IS ALL A
WHOLE OTHER GAME SET UP BY A
COUPLE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE.
YEAH. SO A LITTLE BIT OF A
COINCIDENCE THERE OF COURSE, I'D
BE WEARING CELEBRATORY CLOTHING
IF I COULD, SO. RIGHT. YES.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WIENER. THANK
YOU, SENATOR WIENER SAYS DE
MINIMIS AND COST ONLY, AS TO AS
TO THIS ITEM. AND IF I'M SURE
THAT OTHERS ON AN INDIVIDUAL
BASIS WILL HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY
TO RANDY AS, AS WE DISPERSE
HERE. BUT I WAS HOPING THAT WE
COULD ALL STAND AND, AND GIVE
HIM A BIG ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR
HIS WORK. SO. SPEECH, SPEECH,
SPEECH. I'M JUST GOING TO
ACTUALLY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEETINGS THAT WE'RE GOING. ALL
RIGHT, MR. CHAIR, IF I COULD
JUST QUICKLY SAY FROM THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE AISLE, HE HAS ALSO
BEEN GREAT TO WORK WITH. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MR. VICE CHAIR,
SENATOR WIENER HAS ALREADY
CLOSED. WE NOW HAVE A QUORUM,
AND WE'LL MOVE THE BILL. THE
BILL WAS MOVED BY SENATOR
KENNEDY. YEAH. WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH THE QUORUM AND WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
IMMEDIATELY AFTER YOU ESTABLISH
THE QUORUM, WE'LL JUST GO RIGHT
TO THE ROLL CALL. SENATORS
CORTEZ HERE, CORTEZ HERE. NILO
ALLEN ARCHULETA HERE. ARCHULETA
HERE. BECKER. SHAKESPEARE HERE.
SHAKESPEARE. HERE. DOLLY. DOLLY!
HERE. DODD DODD. HERE. GONZALEZ.
LIMON LIMON. HERE. NEWMAN.
NEWMAN. HERE. NGUYEN PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO. HERE. CIERTO HERE.
SATO. HERE. UMBERG. HERE.
UMBERG. HERE NILO. HERE. NILO.
HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM. ALL
RIGHT, SO THE QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED, THE MOTION'S BY
SENATOR NEWMAN, AND THE ROLL
CALL WILL NOW FOLLOW. THIS IS SB
532. THE MOTION IS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED
IN SENATORS CORTEZ A CORTEZ.
AYE. NILO NILO. AYE. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA. AYE.
BECKER. SHAKESPEARE. SHAKESPEARE
AYE. DALLY. DALLY. AYE. DODD.
GONZALEZ DODD. AYE. GONZALEZ
LIMON. LEMON. AYE NEWMAN.
NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO. AYE. SEYARTO SATO.
AYE. UMBERG. UMBERG. AYE BEALL.
VÆ. CAN YOU FINISH 11 ZERO? DID
YOU FINISH YOUR CALL? NO. WE
NEED TO GO DOWN RIGHT NOW. ÁP.
YEAH. THE BILLS OUT ON AN 11 2
TO 0 VOTE. FIRST FLOOR, 1200.
SORRY. AND WE'RE GOING TO. WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND ADJOURN
THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
MEETING. AGAIN. THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE, PARTICULARLY THE
COMMITTEE STAFF TODAY.